all right here with more reaction author
of the bestseller deception the great Co
coverup Kentucky Senator Ram Paul uh and
by the way speaking of Co fouchi will be
back on Capitol Hill next week this is
going to get interesting uh Senator
great to have you back let's first get
your reaction to the breaking news
tonight and to me the Supreme Court had
to take this case it is too critical it
is too important and how ironic that a
president and a party that claims a
monopoly on the term democracy is
everything but
Democratic without question the Supreme
Court has to hear it when I hear that
it's going to be uh almost a month
though until the hearing and perhaps
longer to the ruling I'm concerned that
even that's too long I think there needs
to be an emergency injunction to shut
down any of the states that are wanting
to do this and just say the decision
will be in 3 or four weeks but you can't
be lining these up because they're
frivolous because they are so likely to
lose on the merits that we're going to
go ahead and shut them down with an
injunction now the reason for that is
every day that it appears as if Donald
Trump might not be on the ballot if that
goes on for three or four weeks that
affects the minds of the voters as they
prepare to vote so the accusation just
the accusation alone makes people think
oh well maybe he's guilty of something
you know you think it wasn't planned
that they use the words Insurrection for
two years now we had a riot where some
people misbehave violently and some
people should have been punished on
January 6th but it was also a bunch of
people Milling around too probably 80%
of them Milling around kind of curious
walk I know one young man who walked in
never said a word to anybody was in the
capital for a minute and a half and he
gets taken thrown down to the floor in
an airport arrested and accused of a
crime so we know that this was a ploy
from the very beginning why didn't they
call it a riot because they said we're
going to use the 14th Amendment we have
this plan we're going to call it
Insurrection but they've so overplayed
their hand here this January 6 was not
the Civil War and nobody believes that
and the more video we've now seen of
these some of these people the shaman
walking around saying hey can I go in
that room and people showing them around
and then policemen saying hey please
don't go in there you're going to get in
trouble the more we see that this was
not some sort of violent Riot for the
most part it was not an Insurrection the
more people say the Democrats are just
crazy to think they can win an election
on this and then they want to add to it
that that we're not going to have Trump
on the ballot they're going to add that
to it you know in in 2020 in the summer
those mostly peaceful riots that took
place
574 we had a couple of dozen dead
Americans thousands of injured cops they
were pelted with bricks rocks bottles
Molotov cocktails billions of property
damage a ton of evidence that nobody
ever looked at you could have arrested
every person involved uh maybe you could
call that Insurrection but then you go
to January 6 why didn't they want to
talk to uh the capital police chief or
follow up on even MB BC news's report
that there was actionable Intelligence
that they didn't act on um why is it
that Muriel Bowser uh rejected in
writing the use of the Guard why didn't
they listen to the Capitol Police Chief
and why didn't they do something to
prevent anything like this from ever
happening again we can't have another
January 6th but they were too um I guess
focused on just bludgeoning Trump and
not looking for a solution to prevent it
ever happening
again I think you need to you need you
know everything you need to know once
you know that the footage that you saw
January 6 played on other networks and
by that house committee that joke of a
committee was done by a Hollywood
producer they went through thousands of
hours and they selected out the worst
images but they didn't show any sort of
images that countered their narrative so
they set up this narrative and they
began using the word and I remember the
first time I heard the words
Insurrection think thinking well that's
bizarre why would they be using the
words Insurrection until the whole thing
gets tied together neatly with the 14th
Amendment it has to be an Insurrection
because of those are the words in the
14th Amendment but the laughable nature
of comparing January 6 to the Civil War
and also the demeaning nature you know
we recently had a candidate ask about
the Civil War well to compare a riot
where there were no guns and no loss of
life from the riers killing anybody to
compare that to the Civil War where
600,000 people died to end slavery at
least half of them wanting to end
slavery um that's just crazy to to think
that that's somehow going to be equated
the Civil War and the riot of January
6th Ram Paul happy new year thanks for
being with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else